at eight o'clock every Tuesday morning
it's training time for the Women's
parliamentary football team a
cross-party group of MPs and a welcome
tonic from the bitterness of the brexit
debate Joe Tanner set up the team last
year and she's been surprised by its
success they've been overwhelmed with
teams wanted to compete and have even
attracted a sponsor weave creates a
really special in 18 months we had our
first game at conference this year and
we've created a fantastic group who
would not normally socialize together
not only spend time together and we have
been having the best fun I just thought
we were gonna have a kick about now and
again and what's turned into this great
experience every Tuesday morning at the
Chelsea Football Club Foundation come
down and train us we actually have
something that's got a bit of purpose to
it for me it's it's a massive deal I
mean I can't believe as someone who is
never sporty it's been many years being
you know on the wrong side of this
girl's rather than the right side I've
spent my life on the sidelines and
suddenly there I am running around with
a ball which I never expected to do him
at the age of 42 the team is already
inspiring the next generation 10 year
old al Hazleton wrote to the team asking
if she could come along to a training
session
she's written about why does she write
to us she wants to prove a point women
are just as important as men with
training out of the way I caught up with
some of the team members it's quite
interesting you kind of think of the two
opposite sides as rivals don't you but
so you had a little bit of cross-party
work from the beginning to try and play
football together to be honest we we
always got on we're just we're just
women that really get on and want to
have a good time love sport and love the
game so actually I would say that Traci
and I worked incredibly well together
while she was minister an IRA shadow
minister anyway I'm still shadow
Minister and I miss her greatly and but
I think the ethos of the team is about
bringing women together regardless of
which political party they're from we
famously were supposed to play our first
match and then couldn't because of votes
on greg's that so we would are stripped
zone and then had a picture in the
chamber and then we had a little kick
about and that was quite fun you meant a
little bit of trouble but what was
really interesting about that and it
wasn't big disrespect it was a big
showing the chamber in a different Lane
because it's always so stuffy and
adversarial this was something it was
fun the cross party thing I find really
intriguing actually because sometimes
you know when it comes to brexit another
really divisive issues at the minute it
feels like there isn't very much across
party work and necessarily happening
that both sides are really entrenched in
their positions I mean is this a bit of
a tonic do you think quite often there
are already crossed party relationships
that are formed on particular issues the
thing about the relationship that we
have is is not just about football it's
not just about politics is lot more that
it knows Internet is I think we've
actually developed quite a good
friendship Anna put something up on
Twitter on World Mental Health Day which
was very honest about her mental
well-being and puts it on the whatsapp
group and actually the whole group sort
of kind of not just came behind her or
supported Hannett but actually were
talking about their own experience
so I think it's something that it's
become really quite deep beyond football
beyond politics and it's that I think
it's really special yeah absolutely like
I've said publicly a number times I'm a
sufferer of anxiety and I certainly have
found in before summer recess and I said
that in my time a little video I did
there was something I was really
struggling with and I've been I've been
fortunate to get support from fans from
colleagues from the football team and
when I picked that up I mean the
response I was I was really taken aback
and yet there's sort of trigger are lots
of people talking about their own
experiences or friends and family I know
that on a on a Tuesday morning if we we
laugh and we swear and we we hug a lot
and we have a really good time but it's
that feeling that you're not alone and
actually you share some of the things
that you've found the darkest moments I
mean I've got trolls really badly the
other night and I didn't even put it on
the group and grace in social media yeah
yeah on social media had someone saved
something really really horrible on
Twitter that was extremely sexist and in
fact Tracy raised it on the group and
everyone came in behind me and support
and I'm sitting on the tube reading this
message knowing that you know my cross
party colleagues will feeling for me and
you know going in to bat for me and
actually I feel quite differing I told
you that I think people really
understand what it must feel like you
know to be quite alone like you were
saying and just hear some of the abuse
that's directed towards me I think it's
hard to explain to people what that
feels like and also I think sometimes
we're scared to say it because people
don't have an awful sympathy for
politicians they see us as the people
who've created the Mystics hxh on you
know rightly or wrongly but in a
position of power and influence and
responsibility and I also think as well
when women talk about sport you do often
get trolled you know with this sort of
kind of get back into the kitchen and
you know what's more you talk about
football yeah I am as Sports Minister I
kept a letter that was sent to me which
was anonymous so they weren't brave
enough to write their name which
basically said things that women know
about cooking cleaning and making babies
things that women do not know about
football I'd like to see you golf
against this person
my manager and coach and you know and
I've spent my entire sort of kind of
adult life involved in grassroots
football and played football since I was
you know a kid I'm sit there thinking
seriously I can but I could do more
keeping up Eastern you made that sort of
stuff you can't really take on a chin
and then laugh at it in in a kind of a
dark way you have to kind of get used to
it that's the world we live in I think
the thing that's really changed now and
that makes my blood run cold is when you
think about your family I live in my
constituency with my four year old and
my six year old and I fear for them I
lose sleep over thinking what if this
person who said this thing to me
actually follows through there how can I
make sure that no one knows where I live
like what alarms can I buy for my mum to
walk with when she picks kids up from
school these are the conversations that
I never thought I'd have to have with
myself in just wanting to stand up for
my community when you were worrying
about your constituents when you're
worrying about politics when you're
wearing about the future of the country
actually this is an hour a week where
you can just you know leave that and you
can just play football you can worry
about whether or not you're going to
score or you know not trip over the pool
or away and it's just oh yeah break
someone's toe bro son did it happen
broke a an excellent member of the teams
too and actually a new beginning as well
no she will I mean I have to say all the
injuries that you can pop on around
where the football injury is by far the
coolest thank you